Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
I, today I wanted to teach you a
variation on trig substitution.
So this is called hyperbolic
trigonometric substitution.
And I'm going to
teach you it just
by going through a nice
example of a question
where it turns out to be useful.
So the question
is the following.
Compute the area of
the region below.
So what's the region?
Well, I have here the hyperbola
x squared minus y squared
equals 1.
And I've chosen a point on the
hyperbola whose coordinates are
(cosh t, sinh t).
So remember that cosh t
is a hyperbolic cosine,
and sinh t is the
hyperbolic sine.
And they're given by the
formulas cosh t equals
e to the t plus e to
the minus t over 2,
and sinh t equals e to the t
minus e to the minus t over 2.
So and we saw in an
earlier recitation video
that this point,
(cosh t, sinh t),
is a point on the right
branch of this hyperbola.
So I've got a region.
So I've got the hyperbola,
I've got that point.
I've drawn a straight
line between the origin
and that point.
So the region that I want
you to find the area of
is this region here.
So it's the region below that
line segment, above the x-axis,
and to the left of this
branch of the hyperbola.
Now, I'm not going
to, I'm not going
to just ask you
to do that alone,
because there's this technique
that I want you to use.
So let's start setting
up the integral together,
and then I'll
describe the technique
and give you a chance to work
it out yourself, to work out
the problem yourself.
So from looking at
this region-- so let's
think about computing
the area of this region.
There are two ways we
could split it up, right?
We could cut it up into
vertical rectangles
and integrate with
respect to x, or we
could cut it up into
horizontal rectangles
and integrate with respect to y.
Now, if we cut it up
into vertical rectangles,
our life is a
little complicated,
because we have to cut the
region into 2 pieces here.
Right?
There's the-- so this
is the point (1, 0),
where the hyperbola
crosses x-axis.
So over here, you know, the
top part is the line segment
and the bottom
part is the x-axis,
and then over here, the top
part is the line segment
and the bottom part
is the hyperbola.
So life is complicated if
we use vertical rectangles.
It's a little bit simpler if
we use horizontal rectangles,
so let's go with that.
You know, the
amount of work will
be similar either way,
but I like this way,
lets you right down
in one integral.
So the area-- OK.
So if we use horizontal
rectangles to compute
the area of a
region, then the area
is, we need to integrate
from the bottom to the top,
whatever the, you know,
the bounds on y are.
And then the thing
we have to integrate
has to be the area of one
of those little rectangles.
So the area of the little
rectangle, its height is dy,
and its length,
or width, I guess,
is the x-coordinate of
its rightmost point,
minus the x coordinate
of its leftmost point.
So OK.
So we need to integrate
from the lowest value of y
to the highest value.
So we start at the
bottom at y equals 0,
and we need to go all
the way up to the top
here, which is y equals sinh t.
So it's an integral
from 0 to sinh t.
OK.
And so we need the
x-coordinate on the right here,
minus the x-coordinate
on the left.
So what's the
x-coordinate on the right?
Well, we need to solve this
equation for x in terms of y.
Right?
This is going to be an
integral with respect to y.
So that if we solve
for this point,
we get x is equal to the square
root of y squared plus 1.
So the right coordinate
is the square root
of y squared plus 1.
And the left
coordinate, this is just
a straight line passing
through the origin,
so its equation is y equals
sinh t over cosh t times x,
or x equals cosh t
over sinh t times y.
So this is minus cosh
t over sinh t times y.
And we're integrating
with respect to y.
OK.
So this is the integral
that we're interested in.
This integral gives us the area.
And just a couple of
things to notice about it.
So t is a constant.
It's just fixed.
So cosh t over sinh t, which
we could also, if we wanted to,
this is the
hyperbolic cotangent.
But that's really
not important at all.
But we could call it
that, if we wanted to.
So this is just a constant.
So we have minus a
constant times y dy.
So this part's
easy to integrate.
So the hard part is
going to be integrating
this y squared plus 1.
Now, one thing you've seen is
that when you have a y squared,
a square root of-- when
you have y y squared
plus 1, one substitution
that sometimes works
is a tangent substitution.
And the reason a tangent
substitution works,
is that you have a trig
identity, tan squared
plus 1 equals secant squared.
In this case, I'd
like to suggest
a different substitution.
All right?
So this integral is the
integral that you want.
And I'd like to suggest
a substitution, which
is that you use a hyperbolic
trig function as the thing
that you substitute.
So in particular, instead
of using, instead of
relying on the trig
identity tan squared
plus 1 equals
secant squared, you
can use the hyperbolic
trig identity,
which is that sinh squared u
plus 1 equals cosh squared u.
So this identity-- so
here we have a something
squared plus 1 equals
something squared.
So the identity this suggests
is to try the substitution y
equals sinh u.
All right?
So this is a hyperbolic
trig substitution.
So why don't you take that hint,
try it out on this integral,
see how it goes.
Take some time, pause the
video, work it out, come back
and we can work it out together.
Welcome back.
Hopefully you had some luck
solving this integral using
a hyperbolic trig substitution.
Let's work it out together,
see if my answer matches
the one that you came up with.
So as I said before, this
integral comes in two parts.
There's the hard
part, the square root
of y squared plus
1 part, and there's
the easy part, this y part.
So before I make
the substitution,
let me just deal
with the easy part.
So I'll do that over here.
So we have the one
part of the area,
or one part of the
integral, really,
is the integral from 0 to sinh
t of minus cosh t over sinh t
times y dy.
OK.
So this is just a constant,
so it's a constant times y.
So this is equal to-- well, it's
the same constant comes along,
minus cosh t over sinh t,
times y squared over 2,
for y between 0 and this
upper bound, sinh t.
So that's equal-- OK.
So when y is 0, this is just 0.
So this equals minus
cosh t sinh t over 2.
So that's the easy
part of integral.
So in order to compute
the total area,
we need to add this
expression that we just
computed to the integral
of this first part.
So that's what we
need to compute next.
And that's what we're going
to use the hyperbolic trig
substitution on.
So we're going to compute
the integral from 0
to sinh t of the square
root of y squared plus 1 dy.
And we're going to use
the substitution sinh
u equals y, or y equals sinh u.
OK.
So we need, what do I need?
I need what dy is, and I
need to change the bounds.
So dy-- I'm sorry,
I'm going to flip
this around to take
the-- so dy is,
I need the differential of
sine u-- sorry, of sinh u.
And so we saw in the earlier
hyperbolic trig function
recitation that that's
cosh u du, or if you like,
you could just differentiate
using the formulas
that we know for sinh and cosh.
And we need bounds.
So when y is 0, we need
sinh of something is 0.
And so it happens
that that value is 0.
So if you remember the
graph of the function,
or you can just check
in the formula, when
sinh is 0, when t is 0,
that's when you get sinh is 0.
It's the only time e to the
t equals e to the minus t.
OK.
So when y is 0, then u is 0, and
when y is sinh t, then u is t.
Right?
Because sinh u is sinh t.
So under the substitution, this
becomes the integral from 0
to t now, from u equals
0 to t, of-- well, OK.
So this becomes the square
root of sinh squared u plus 1,
and then dy is times cosh u du.
OK.
Now the reason we made this
substitution in the first place
is that this, we can use a
hyperbolic trig identity here.
So sinh squared u plus 1
is just cosh squared u,
and square root of cosh
squared u is cosh u.
Remember that cosh
u is positive,
so we don't have to worry
about an absolute value here.
So this is the integral from
0 to t of cosh squared u du.
OK.
So at this point, there are
a couple of different things
you can do.
One is that you can, just
like when we have certain trig
identities, we have
corresponding hyperbolic trig
identities that we
could try out here.
So we could try
something like that.
Another thing you can
do, is you can just
go back to the formula, right?
Cosh t has a simple formula
in terms of exponentials,
so you can go back to this
formula and you can plug in.
So let's just try that
quickly, because that's
a sort of easy way
to handle this.
So this is cosh squared u du.
So I'm going to write-- OK.
Carry that all the way up here.
So this is the
integral from 0 to t.
Well, if you take the
formula for hyperbolic cosine
and square it, what
you get, I'm going
to do this all in one step,
is you e to the 2u plus 2 plus
e to the minus 2u over 4 du.
OK.
And so now this is, once
you've replaced everything
with exponentials, this
is easy to integrate.
This is-- so e to the 2u, the
integral is e to the 2u over 2,
so that comes over 8.
2 over 4, you integrate
that, and that's
just 2u over 4,
which is u over 2.
And now the last one
is minus e to the minus
2u over 8 between 0 and t.
OK.
So now we take the
difference here.
At t, we get e to the 2t
over 8 plus t over 2 minus
e to the minus 2t over 8.
Minus-- OK.
And when u is equal-- so
that was at u equals t.
At u equals 0, we get
1/8 plus 0 minus 1/8.
So that's just 0.
OK.
So this is what we got for
that part of the integral.
So OK, so we've now split
the integral into two pieces.
We computed one piece,
because it was just easy,
we're integrating a polynomial.
We computed the other piece,
which was more complicated,
using a hyperbolic
trig substitution.
The whole integral is the
sum of those two pieces.
So now the whole integral,
I have to take this piece,
and I have to add
it to the thing
that I computed
for the other piece
before, which was
somewhere-- where did it go?
Here it is, right here.
Which was minus cosh
t sinh t over 2.
OK.
So I'm going to save
you a little arithmetic,
and I'm going to observe that
minus cosh t sinh t over 2
is exactly equal to the
minus e to the 2t over 8,
plus e to the minus 2t over 8.
So adding these two
expressions together gives us--
so the first expression,
minus cosh t sinh t over 2,
is minus e to the
2t over 8 plus e
to the minus 2t
over 8, plus-- OK.
Plus what we've got
right here, which
is e to the 2t over 8 minus
e to the minus 2t over 8
plus t over 2.
And that's exactly
equal to t over 2.
OK.
So this is the area of that sort
of hyperbolic triangle thing
that we started out
with at the beginning.
So let me just walk back
over there for a second.
So we used this hyperbolic
trig substitution
in order to compute that
the area of this triangle
is t over 2.
And I just want
to-- first of all,
I want to observe that
that's a really nice answer.
So that's kind of cool.
The other thing that
I want to observe
is that this is a very close
analogy with something that
happens in the case of regular
circle trigonometric functions.
Which is, if you look
at a regular circle,
and you take the point cosine
theta comma sine theta,
then the area of this little
triangle here is theta over 2.
So in this case, u
doesn't measure an angle,
but it does measure an area
in exactly the same way
that theta measures an area.
So there's a really
cool relationship
there between the
hyperbolic trig function
and the regular trig function.
So that's just a
kind of cool fact.
The useful piece of
knowledge that you
can extract from
what we've just done,
though, is that you can use this
hyperbolic trig substitution
in integrals of certain forms.
So in the same way that trig
substitutions are suggested
by certain forms
of the integrand,
hyperbolic trig
substitutions are also
suggested by certain
forms of the integrand,
and often you have a choice
about which one to use.
And in this particular instance,
a hyperbolic trig substitution
worked out quite nicely.
Much more nicely than
a trig substitution
would have worked out.
So it's just another
tool for your toolbox.
I'll end with that.